Você sabia que o seu cérebro pode estar
funcionando como um motor flex esse
tempo todo e você nem imaginava? Olha só
que descoberta impressionante.
Pesquisadores da Universidade de
Queensland acabaram de publicar na
Nature Metabolism que nossos neurônios
não vivem só de glicose, não. Eles
também queimam gordura para funcionar.
Pois é, durante décadas a gente
acreditou que o cérebro só usava açúcar
como combustível. Mas veja bem, os
cientistas estavam estudando um gene
ligado à paraplegia espástica e
descobriram que quando esse gene falha,
o equilíbrio de gorduras no cérebro se
perde e os neurônios param de funcionar
direito. O mais interessante é que nós
já sabíamos que os neurônios usavam
corpos cetônicos que são derivados das
gorduras como combustível alternativo.
Mas esse novo achado vai além, mostra
que eles queimam diretamente pequenas
moléculas de gordura para se comunicar
entre si. Nos testes com os animais,
quando forneceram ácidos grassos
saturados livres, a função dos neurônios
voltou ao normal. Isso só reforça, ainda
mais que o cérebro não depende só de
glicose para sua nutrição.
Explica porque dietas como a ketoflex t
dado resultados tão bons em pacientes
com alzheim e outras doenças
neurológicas. Não é novidade total para
quem já trabalha com medicina funcional,
mas agora temos evidência científica
robusta.
confirmando que a gente já vinha
observando na prática clínica. Então
fica a reflexão, será que não tá na hora
de repensar como você alimenta o seu
cérebro, porque ele definitivamente não
vive só de carboidrato.